Good morning.
As you can see from the title of today's lecture habitats at Herculaneum and
early Roman interior decoration,
we're going to be concentrating once again at least in the first half of the
lecture on domestic architecture in Campania.
We're going to look at several houses in Herculaneum and then we're going to
move from there to begin our discussion of early Roman interior decoration,
namely the first and second styles of Roman wall painting and what you'll see
makes them particularly relevant to what we've been discussing thus far.
This term is the fact that in both the first and second styles,
architecture is depicted in these paintings and we're going to see some very
interesting relationships between that and the built the built monuments that
we've talked about thus far this semester.
Just to remind you of the location of Herculaneum,
which is usually called the sister,
city of palm pay because of that locale.
Uh,
we see it on the map here.
Pompei is down in this location.
Herculaneum is to the north east of palm,
pay closer to Naples.
And Pompei is,
as you can see.
And note also that the city of bus gory all lay bus Allah,
which is located between almost equal distant,
a little bit closer to Pompei then Herculaneum but in between the two.
And I pointed out to now,
because we're going to look at an important,
uh,
room with paintings from the city of Bus Gory Ali today as well.
Here you see a view a Google earth,
a fly over of Herculaneum as it looks today,
uh,
is very helpful because you can see a couple of things here that I want you to
keep in mind as we look at this city.
One that although most of the city of palm pay has been excavated,
only about a quarter or 25% of the city of perculate IOM has been excavated.
So we have much less than less at Herculaneum than we do for palm pay.
And what we're missing for the most part is the public architecture.
We don't have a great amphitheater from Herculaneum.
We don't have a theater and a music hall complex.
Uh,
we don't have,
we think we might have part of the basilica,
but we're not absolutely sure.
We don't have the great large a forum space that we have in palm pay.
So we're missing a lot of that public architecture at Herculaneum,
which gives us less of a sense of what the city was originally like,
at least in its public face.
Although there's no doubt that that material is still lies beneath the ground.
So we have only a quarter of the city,
mostly the residential part of the city or part of the residential part of the
city.
But there are several houses there that are extremely,
um,
give us,
uh,
provide,
information,
especially about what was going between the eruption of,
between the earthquake and the eruption of the Soviet 62 to 79 that are
extremely valuable in terms of giving us a sense,
again,
of the evolution of Roman domestic architecture.
The other,
the other issue that this particular view raises is the reason why Herculaneum
is less well excavated then palm pay.
And the reason for that has to do,
and you can see it well here,
has to do with the fact that the modern city grew up on top of the ancient city.
Uh,
and uh,
they were able at one point to clear part of it for excavation,
but they have not been able to clear the rest.
It's a political nightmare,
you know,
to have to deal,
you have to relocate all the people who live in this area and have lived in this
area for a very long time.
That's politically a very difficult thing to do.
It also is extremely costly.
So thus far,
only 25% of Herculaneum revealed.
Let's all hope that at some point someday Italy can sort this out and find a way
to excavate the rest of this extraordinary city.
You can see from this view that I took as,
this is one of the views that you get as you enter the site,
the current location today.
But I think you can see very well here again what I'm talking about,
the relationship between the ancient,
ancient city lower ground level that has been on earth through excavation.
You can see a peristyle court of one of the houses here,
for example,
a button.
You can see the way in which the modern city rings,
uh,
the site.
And again,
what a challenge it would be to,
uh,
to remove that modern city and to reveal the rest of Herculaneum.
Here's another view where you can also see some of the remains of the ancient
city of these residences and so on and their relationship to the rest of the
town.
With regard to the history of Herculaneum,
it is very similar to the history of Pompei.
One difference is that the city of Herculaneum was supposedly founded by
Hercules,
hence its name Herculaneum.
But in other respects,
the history again is,
is quite comparable.
Uh,
we know for example,
that the city of Herculaneum was overseeing for a while by that same metallic
tribe called the Oskins who were then,
uh,
who were then,
conquered by the Sam Nights.
And the Sam nights took over Herculaneum and it was during the Sam night period
and Herculaneum that we begin to see the same kind of architectural development
that we saw also in Pompei.
We also know that the,
that those in Herculaneum,
the citizens of Herculaneum,
the leaders of Herculaneum got involved in the social wars,
as did those in palm pay,
and that the city of Herculaneum was conquered by Rome in [inaudible] 89 BC in
89 BC.
So Herculaneum becomes a Roman colony in 89 BC thereafter.
We know,
and of course at that point just is in palm pay.
The Romans begin to build buildings in the Roman manner.
From that point on,
we know,
again,
comparable development.
We know that the hurts that in Herculaneum they also witnessed that very serious
earthquake,
an earthquake that,
that also a destroyed significant parts of the city of Herculaneum.
And they too went through that frenzied 17 year period of rebuilding a,
but again,
just as at palm pay.
It was for not because the city of Herculaneum was also covered by the ash and
lava of Vesuvius.
However,
there's one major difference,
uh,
that has to do with the way that ash and lava fell.
Uh,
we talked about the fact that at pump pay there was actually quite a bit of
notice that the ash and lava,
uh,
came down on the city fairly gradually and that there was time for people to
escape and that most of them did except for those full hardy souls who decided
to wait it out,
uh,
which we discussed a couple of lectures ago,
but in Herculaneum,
uh,
it happened much more rapidly.
And in fact,
it became very clear very quickly that a huge blanket of lava was headed toward
the city.
And needless to say,
that encouraged people to leave a pronto.
And we thought at least for a very long time that that's in fact what had
happened,
that everybody had escaped the onslaught of Vesuvius.
What happened after,
uh,
that that blanket of lava and Gulf,
the city is it hermetically sealed the city,
hermetically seal the city,
uh,
in such a way that materials that have been lost at Pompei were preserved at
Herculaneum.
And the most,
the best example of that is would we have almost no wood.
What is not a material that it stands the test of time terribly well and we have
almost no wood from Pompei but from the city of Herculaneum,
we have a considerable amount of wood.
And this just has to do with this with the fact again that the city was so
hermetically sealed by that blanket of love.
And I can show you a few examples of what survives in wood,
for example,
this bad or part of a bed a that still preserved.
As you can see here with the wooden legs,
uh,
a wooden partition in one of the houses to divide one section,
kind of like a modern Pobo wall to divide one section,
uh,
of the,
structure from another.
Uh,
you can see also the wooden frames around the doors and around the windows are
also preserved as are these wooden beams that you can see over the doorways and
over the,
uh,
over the windows,
mostly over the doorways,
those wooden beams also made out of wood.
And this is the most famous example and one that everybody sees as you wander
the streets of Herculaneum,
uh,
the Causa gras teach show,
which we see here.
And you can see that even the balcony which is made out of wood is extremely
well preserved.
So this provides evidence that we don't have pump from Pompei.
That's extremely valuable in terms of understanding a Roman building practice.
I mentioned already though,
that we didn't think anyone,
we thought that all of the,
those who lived in Herculaneum had escaped from the CVS.
Uh,
but it turns out that was not in fact the case as recently as the 1980s,
some archeologists,
uh,
were,
doing some excavating down at the sea walls of the city of Herculaneum.
And Lo and behold,
they came upon a cache of skeletons.
And I show you some of those skeletons here in those skeletons are in the same
kinds of positions at the body as the bodies that we saw at Tom pay in that
clearly a number of them have huddled together for the protection,
a few child protection as it turned out in here.
Another one who's raising himself or herself in an attempt to,
uh,
to,
to survive somehow,
uh,
this awful event that has occurred.
Uh,
we find these skeletons and they found these skeletons near the sea wall.
And,
um,
what they've concluded from this two things.
One,
again,
the difference in the lava that fell on Herculean,
we can see that it not only preserved would,
it also preserves bone,
which is why the skeletons are still visible here.
Whereas it pump pay everything,
uh,
you know,
everything decomposed at palm pay.
So the situation,
again,
quite different.
But they've all also been able to determine that what clearly happened here is
again,
because there was so much notice people fled.
And where did they flee?
They fled toward the water because they were right on the sea.
Uh,
they had a lot of boats and the hope was that they could ferry,
uh,
everybody out from the city.
And for the most part they were successful.
But there was a certain group that unfortunately got left behind and it was
their remains that were discovered in the 1980s.
It's amazing what these bodies can tell us about some of the people who live
there.
And I'll just give you a little sense of a couple of the,
of the storylines.
Uh,
here is,
uh,
the,
the skeleton of a woman.
And you can see that this woman has,
if you look very closely at her left hand to or for fingers,
you can,
she,
she has rings on two of her fingers and those are larger views of those very
rings.
Two rings with green and red stones,
the redstone,
you can see it,
the little bird depicted on it.
These were her rings.
Consequently,
the archeologists called her the Ring Lady,
uh,
or the rich should be the rings lady.
Uh,
but here she is with her two rings and you can see that she also had next to her
side,
these two absolutely gorgeous.
A snake golden snake bracelets,
sort of Allah,
Cleopatra,
Cleopatra ask that she obviously loved,
uh,
and took with her,
when she attempted to escape from the city.
And an even more poignant story is this one.
What we're looking at here is the head of a woman,
a young woman.
Uh,
the,
uh,
excavators have determined,
and if you can look,
if you look at the top of her head,
you will see that a tuft of hair is actually preserved.
It looks dark in this image,
but it's actually blonde.
So they'd been able to determine,
this was a young blonde woman who lived in Herculaneum and uh,
you can see the small size of the skeleton and below this is not hers.
It's obviously her,
the fetus,
the baby,
uh,
she was seven months pregnant.
They've been able to determine and so they have found the bones of the baby as
well.
And you can see them here in the excavators,
the excavation reports,
they talk about the fact that the bones of the baby of the infant,
of the unborn child are so fragile that it was like picking up eggshells,
uh,
when they were trying to,
to,
uh,
piece,
this skeleton together.
So it's incredible the kind of information that archeologists have been able to
glean from those trying to escape Herculaneum on that fateful day in August of
79.
One other sad story is just that they did actually find the remains of one
child.
This is sort of like the story of the dog at palm pay.
One child,
uh,
whose remains were left in this little crib in one house and again,
the bones are preserved because of this.
The circumstance of the particular configuration of the law of,
of the bones of that,
uh,
of that small child are also preserved in this crib,
in one of the houses in Herculaneum
to turn to the city itself.
I show you now a plan of Herculaneum or at least the excavated part of
Herculaneum.
Uh,
that gives you some sense of what is there.
And I've already mentioned that we simply,
you won't see any big amphitheater and plant already major,
uh,
forum complex and so on and so forth.
We simply don't have that evidence in the excavated part.
But what you do see is comparable to the residential area.
Pompei.
Uh,
you can see a series of major thoroughfares,
crossing it with one another.
We can't be sure since we don't have the whole city,
which is the main Cardo and which is the main deck [inaudible] of the city.
Uh,
but they are certainly certainly laid out at a quite regular pattern with shops
and houses interspersed with one another.
As you can see a extremely well here.
Again,
we don't,
we as far as we know,
we really were quite sure we don't have any of the major public buildings,
but there are a couple of,
of,
uh,
of structures here and there that do tell us something.
Here's an arch for example.
Uh,
that may have been on one of the more important thoroughfares of the city.
and we certainly have a sh have shops and,
and the like along the way.
And I can actually show you a few,
uh,
views of,
of shops and the city streets and so on.
That gives you a good sense that Herculaneum was very similar looking to Pompei.
If you look at the street here as the street from the city of Herculaneum,
you can see the same uh,
multi-sided stones for the pavement.
You can see the same sidewalks,
you can see the same drains in Herculaneum.
You can see the same Rutten marks.
What you don't see,
and I started a post on this yesterday,
what you don't see or stepping stones,
there are no preserve stepping stones in Herculaneum.
There are lots of preserves stepping in Palm Bay and I was mulling this over
yesterday in a way,
even beyond what I have tended to in the past about these stepping stones.
Thinking about could I think of any other examples in any other Roman city I've
ever been including Rome itself with is actually quite a bit of preserved uh,
pavement here and there out on the,
via Apia in the Roman forum and so on and so forth.
And I can't think of a single other site off the top of my head where we find
stepping stone.
So I just put that out as a thought question for all of us to see whether we
can,
whether I'm missing something or whether it's conceivable that Pompei may have
been exceptional in this regard rather than the norm here we see a amphoras
these clay amphoras in which wine or oil were kept.
So a wine or an oil shop there.
And then of course our favorite,
the fast food stand,
the Thermop Oleum,
uh,
Herculaneum had plenty of Thermop Olia,
very similar to those in palm pay.
So you can imagine for the most part are quite similar,
uh,
looking city.
I mentioned though that the evidence that we do have is mostly for residential
architecture and there are three houses in particular that I want to focus on
because they give us information,
uh,
that goes beyond the information that I've been able to give you from the houses
that we looked at in Pompei.
The first one I want to look at is the so called Sam night house at Pompei,
at Herculaneum.
It dates to the second century BC and you see it in plan here.
It's a very simple house.
So second century BC that tells you what it tells you that it's early,
but it's already in that hellenized don't miss period,
which began in the second century BC.
So we look to see which plan it conforms to.
Is it,
does it conform to the dome?
Is he tall or the d or the Nice Dome as well?
At first it looks like it conforms to the Dome [inaudible] because you can see
it's quite simple.
Uh,
it has the basic core.
You come in here into the foul case.
There are cells on either side,
the cell lie,
uh,
these cell I are indeed sell lie.
They are,
they open up only to the house and not to the outside.
They have not been transformed into shops.
We see the atrium here,
we see the [inaudible] of the Atrium and there was of course a comp [inaudible]
up above.
We see a very small number of cubic ula.
Uh,
just a couple over here and we don't seem to see the usual wings in less.
This one over here,
although there seems to be some sort of staircase on that side,
served as in part as the wing.
Uh,
and so,
and one of those rooms,
probably the left one served as the dining room.
There's no cordless,
there's no Paris style.
So again,
at first it looks like a pretty simple example of the end even and even
simplified version of a typical domus Etol Alica.
But when we walk into the atrium,
which is very well preserved today we see something quite different.
They focus in this particular house was the atrium.
You can tell it's an atrium.
You can see the calm pluvial up above.
We're looking here at the entrance way through the FAO case.
These are the doors into the two cells,
one on either side.
This is a door into one of the,
one of the only two cubic ula,
uh,
in this structure.
Uh,
you can see also that the,
um,
the patron and designer of this particular house want to want it.
You can see that this is a hellenized miss in the sense that they have
incorporated,
uh,
pilasters here on either side of the,
um,
of the wall next to the entrance way.
But most interesting of all is what has happened in what seems to be a second
story.
Uh,
for the atrium.
They have expanded.
They have moved,
they have,
they have developed the atrium even more vertically than has been the case
before.
By adding this,
uh,
this,
blind,
a blind gallery blind gallery up at the top,
which on three sides is again closed.
You can see the enclosed wall,
but on the fourth side,
which I can't,
which I don't have an image to show you the fourth side,
there's an open to this,
an open logia.
There's open space between the columns.
So blind gallery on three sides open logia on the other side,
the open logia of course adding additional light,
bringing additional light into the atrium.
So a very elaborate treatment of the atrium,
which shows us not only the esteem in which this particular patron,
uh,
held the atrium,
but also this interesting incorporation of columns in a different way than we've
seen before.
Making them the high point of this room by placing them in the second story,
they are ionic columns.
Notice also this sort of lattice work fence,
uh,
that in circles it,
we'll see that kind of lattice work fence.
Also enrollment painting.
You can see in fact the remains of some paint on the walls and the walls,
uh,
behind this were painted.
So a very,
very opulent,
uh,
opulent atrium that shows again,
this interest in building vertically and adding some interest at the upper most
part to create the sense of two stories.
This is an a development,
this is in fact even early for that,
uh,
in the second century BC,
the two most important houses,
however,
at Herculaneum are the,
uh,
house of the Mosaic Atrium and the house of the stacks.
And I want to look at both of those houses with you today.
I'm going to start with the house of the Mosaic Atrium.
You can see from this plan which comes from the word Perkins Textbook.
You can see from this plan that they are literally side by side.
They essentially share a wall as you can see here.
Uh,
and I wanna there they are very important in terms of the development,
not only of a residential architecture in Campania in the late first century,
a d but also as a premonition of what's to come in much later.
Residential architecture.
Again,
I'm going to look at both of them.
Uh,
and we'll start first with the mosaic atrium.
If you look at the top of the plan,
the northern most part of the plan,
and this house by the way,
does,
as you can see from the monument list,
uh,
does date to a add 62 to 79.
So at the very end of a domestic architecture development in palm pay,
if we look at the upper most part,
the north,
you will see that if you enter the house at the Arrow and you look ahead,
you would think you look at the vista head and see the Atrium and the to bleed
them.
You would think you were in a typical Domus Etol a type house.
It's got those three main elements.
It's got the foul case,
it's got the atrium with an employer,
Viacom and accomplished via miss.
We'll see.
And it's got a to bleed them all on access with one another.
But as you're standing in the atrium looking toward the Tbilisi them,
you're kind of looking at this to bleed them and sang to yourself.
This is not the,
to glean them.
I know this is not that to bleeding and I'm used to,
this is not the to bleed them and most of the houses that I know,
it's designed in a very different way.
And what,
what is it that you see in plan that indicates to us that it's designed in a
different way?
Does anyone see what it is
it has?
Are they columns?
Look closely.
They are they,
are they round?
No.
They're square.
So they're either peers or their columns on bases that are square.
But,
but you're right,
there are architectural members in here.
It turns out their peers,
but so there their peers in here.
Okay.
Uh,
what else?
What about the,
the,
the actual plan itself.
How were those peers?
What's the relationship of those peers to the,
to the room design
there someone over there.
Is that right?
Freestanding.
Yup.
What else does it remind you of a plan we've seen in another context,
you're looking at a central space divided by two isles by architectural members.
In this case by peers,
a basilica.
It's a basilican plan.
Basilican plan,
Central Nave to side offs.
What's a basilican plan doing in a house?
Is this a basilica or a law court?
No,
it's actually a winter banqueting room,
but a winter banqueting room in the shape of a basilica.
And I make lot of that because we'll see this happening with increasing
frequency enrollment architecture and that is a certain building type that was
developed for one kind of building.
In this case,
a Basilican plan developed for law courts,
uh,
begins to be used for a nother kind of room.
In this case,
a winter banqueting hall.
And I like to call this to sort of interchangeability of form that you can do.
You can develop a certain plan for a certain kind of structure,
but then be creative enough to realize that you could use that same plan in
another environment in a different but interest in way.
And that's exactly what happens here.
Now,
needless to say,
the scale is actually fairly large,
but this does not look like a huge basilica.
It's,
it's,
it's brought down to domestic size scale as you can see here.
So that's a very interesting development.
It's very well preserved.
And I'll show it to you in a moment.
So once you get into the atrium,
then you have to take an abrupt right in order to see the peristyle court.
And the peristyle court is very,
very large.
We've talked about the fact that there was an increasing interest in the
peristyle as a key component of a Roman house.
Uh,
and we see that very clearly here in fact that the peristyle is really beginning
to take pride of place away from the atrium cause the atrium is almost beginning
to go the way of the,
to bleed them in the sense that it's becoming a kind of passageway.
It's not an end in itself,
it's becoming or they tend to bleed a ends and their selves.
They are a passageway into this huge peristyle.
If you look at the plan of the Paris style,
uh,
you can see that there are columns with those columns are engaged into the wall
and that's well preserved.
I'll show it to you in a moment.
And then also extremely interesting is now on axis with the Atrium and bill.
Huge peristyle is tr,
tr is the trickling IOM or the dining room.
And look at the size of that trickling IOM and look at the fact that the try
Klinean opens both off the Paris style and also has an opening on this way,
on this end,
toward the front,
uh,
toward the other side,
excuse me,
of the,
uh,
of the house.
And this is the side.
This is the side,
the southern side that faces the sea.
And Herculaneum was very close.
I'll show you.
I restored view that makes this clear in a moment.
Herculaneum was very close to the sea and this,
these two houses were probably among the two most expensive houses in
Herculaneum because they had the best views of the sea.
They were very up high above the seawall and they looked right out at the sea.
So this,
the,
the way they've designed this very large try Klinean to benefit from being able
to see both the peristyle and views out over the sea even while you were dining.
Uh,
there seems to have been a,
um,
call a colonnade over here,
uh,
so views through columns out to the sea and then these two rooms at d,
these are,
as you can see here,
the [inaudible],
d I a,
e t,
a singular,
d,
I,
a,
e t,
e,
plural.
These are,
uh,
these are rooms that are set aside for sort of summer pleasures,
summer pleasures near the,
near the panoramic window,
uh,
that you can look out to the Cecil place to relax and enjoy the sunshine on the
southern end views of the sea,
a special room set up,
set aside,
adjust for that kind of panoramic viewing and the like.
So this move again toward vista toward panorama that we've been talking about
before.
So some very important changes here.
Uh,
that signal where Roman residential architecture,
we'll go in the future.
I'm going to wait on the plan of the stags till we finish with the mosaic
atrium.
The mosaic atrium.
You can see a view into the atrium today.
You can see why the house is called the house of the mosaic Atrium because of
the very well preserved a black and white strikingly striking a black and white
mosaic that we find there.
Uh,
and you can see how well preserved the employee IOM is,
uh,
with the mosaic decoration around that.
You can also see,
however,
if you look carefully at this image,
you probably noticed it already that the floor undulates why does the floor
undulate if Laura and Jill lakes,
because of that heavy blanket of lava that entered into,
uh,
Herculaneum that,
that,
uh,
made it's presence known,
and that distorted the shape of the,
um,
of the,
uh,
floor of the Atrium about fortunately preserved it at the same time,
which is great.
Uh,
we're looking from the atrium into the bleed them and we see that Basilican
form,
uh,
that we described already before.
A central nave of back wall side aisles on either,
you can see this side,
but same on this side is on this side,
side aisles,
uh,
and uh,
circulation of space among them.
Uh,
and you can also see if you look very carefully and have another view in a
moment that there are windows here as well,
windows that allow light into the system.
When we talked about the basilica of Pompei,
I mentioned to you that the Basilica Pompei did not have a clear story.
C,
l e r e s t o r.
Y did not have a clear story,
but that we would,
we would begin to see the development of the clear story later.
We see it here.
This use of a clear story is the placement of windows in that second story to
allow light into the structure.
It has been developed here.
It's very important to architectural development and we're going to see again,
the ramifications of that into the future.
Here's another view of the,
um,
of,
of what is up this banqueting hall.
And by the way,
the technical name for this and I have it on the monument lists for you is the
Egyptian [inaudible] or the [inaudible],
the [inaudible] or if it's easier for you,
the Egyptian Ecos,
uh,
that,
that this particular form of banqueting hall in the shape of a basilica.
Uh,
this,
this view is helpful not only because you can see the peers better,
uh,
but also because you can see the windows better,
the clear story system that allows light into the space.
And you can also see this ubiquitously use of white and red for the peers in
this case,
just as they are usually used for columns.
The upper most part of the pier a is white,
and then they painted the bottom red.
So very similarly to the kind of decor we saw also in Pompei.
This is of course the peristyle court.
Uh,
you can see it here and you can see the way in which these columns have been
engaged into the wall of the garden court.
Uh,
you can also see this interesting use of combination of stone and tile,
uh,
for the construction.
Also interesting.
As you look at the rooms that line the side of the peristyle,
uh,
you can see how open up how opened up they have become.
We don't see that severe wall that we saw in the very earliest domus Vitalik a
with no windows is you'll recall there are lots of windows here and they are
large windows and they are allowing light into the structure,
not just on the front where the views are,
but on the other sides of the building.
This is again a very important change,
uh,
and one that is going to have again important ramifications for the future.
Note also that the famous palm pay in red is used to pay to decorate the walls.
So that's the house of the mosaic atrium.
Now let's turn to the house of the stags,
the house of the Stag,
so called because of a sculpture that was found there that I'll show you a bit
later.
If we look at the house of the stags,
we see some interesting things happening as well.
That seemed to parallel the development.
We've already described this house to be built between 62 and 79.
The entrance in this case is on the upper most,
right,
uh,
right here.
And you can see that you enter in along the Fao,
ks along by the throat of the house into what is designated as the atrium.
But that atrium is not like any other atrium we've seen thus far this semester.
What's missing?
The [inaudible],
the employ of IOM is missing if there's no improving them.
There's no comp Bluebeam,
uh,
which means that the room is not open to the sky and we call a,
we call it an atrium that has no opening.
And I put this on the monument list for you and Atrium test today to not them
and Atrium test due to Naadam is an atrium that has no,
uh,
no opening to the sky.
And that's the case here.
That also is,
tends to under play this space because there's no longer,
as interesting as it was when it had that wonderful basin and the s and the
skylight and so on and so forth.
And if you look at the plan,
you'll see it's very interesting.
It has lots of openings on various sides.
So here,
this is a really good example of what I was hinting at before.
And that is the atrium beginning to go the way of the [inaudible],
the atrium beginning to become a passageway from one part of the house to
another.
It really is merely a passageway from the outside,
from the foul ks into the other rooms of the house.
What have received the greatest emphasis by the patron and by the designer is
not the atrium,
but is the Tri Clint IOM or dining hall.
And you can see that there are two of them.
And they are,
they are placed in relationship to one another axial relationship to one
another.
So they're almost talking to one of,
there's like a dialogue,
uh,
an architectural dialog between that smaller tripe Klinean and this larger try
Klinean across an open courtyard,
of course,
an open courtyard.
So here we see again the tri minium beginning to emerge as the single most
important room in the house,
which obviously sig signals,
uh,
what's going on in these houses,
that people are beginning to use them even more than they did before.
Uh,
not only as places of business,
but it's places to,
uh,
to enjoy,
um,
fabulous dinner parties.
Uh,
and while you can look out over the sea,
and in fact,
if you look at this try Columbia and the larger one you can see again,
it opens both off the garden court and also opens toward the south of where you
would have seen the views of the sea.
All of this very deliberate,
we see the d day,
I tie here as well these summer living spaces with views out over the water.
And here we see an interesting detail,
which is a kind of,
um,
kiosk or gazebo that's located in the front and that actually still survives and
I'll show that to you in a moment.
So again,
quite momentous changes,
uh,
in architectural,
in,
in a residential architecture,
in Herculaneum and in Campania in general,
in the late first century.
A D this is a restored view,
very helpful because we can use it to illustrate a number of things.
We can use it to illustrate how close to the sea Herculaneum was.
Uh,
we can use it to look at the seawalls that I talked about before.
We can use it to look at the,
the harbor,
the,
the small boat dock that was down here with boats waiting.
This,
this was the place that people ran to,
uh,
in order to escape,
the onslaught of Vesuvius.
Uh,
and this is exactly in the seawall is exactly where those bodies were found.
So they made it this far,
but not far enough.
And we can pick out both the house of the mosaic Atrium right here and the house
of the stags over here,
both of them,
very large.
As you can see,
you can see in the case,
here's the northern end.
You can see in this case for the house of the Mosaic Atrium,
the [inaudible] of the atrium that we described,
the mosaic atrium.
And you can see the open court here.
You can see the,
the side that faces the sea.
And how opened up it is how many windows there were,
how much,
how open to the d,
the Iti on either side where you could get nice views here.
The house of the stags,
same sort of thing.
You see no opening whatsoever in the northern end.
Uh,
no as opening in the ceiling,
no complete Liam are you,
do you see the,
to try Clinique of facing one another across the open court and you see that
little gazebo,
uh,
entrance where the Gazebo that again looks out toward the sea,
that distinctive detail here.
A couple more views just to show you quickly the,
that if you go and visit Herculaneum,
you can still see those seawalls.
Uh,
they're made out of concrete.
As you can see,
they're well worth taking a look at.
Uh,
and uh,
this is a view taken.
This is one of the ways you can enter into the city taken across.
You can see the Suvi,
it's in the background and you can see,
uh,
the,
this is the house of the Mosaic Atrium that we've been looking at.
This is the house of the stags.
Can you can tell the difference because of the Little Gazebo,
little kiosk in front.
Uh,
and here you can see again,
so well the way this is positioned high up on the wall with spectacular views of
the sea,
uh,
and this opening up of the wall to allow maximum vista,
Matt Maximum Panorama.
Uh,
through that,
through those spaces in the house,
note the Kioski or,
and then note this other entrance.
I'm going to show you both of those in detail.
This is a little gazebo.
As you can see,
it rests on peers.
I was obviously a very pleasant place to sit with marble furniture and have a
glass of wine out here looking out over the sea.
And you can see once again that the peers have been stuccoed over white on top,
red on the bottom,
just as we have seen is so characteristic.
Also Pompei.
Uh,
and right behind that other entrance way that I can also show you a,
where you can see if you look very closely,
you can see not only the red paint on the pilasters,
but also the very elaborate decoration and blue and white of the pediment above.
This gives you some sense also the kind of decorative sculpture there would have
been in buildings like this,
the marble tables,
uh,
the um,
the,
these wonderful,
uh,
statues.
There are two of them,
have a stags being attacked by hounds.
Uh,
and these are,
these stags are what have given this house.
It's name the house of the stags.
I want to turn from a Roman residential architecture in Herculaneum and the
developments there too.
Early Roman wall decoration,
painted decoration.
And as I said at the beginning,
specifically to the first and second styles of Roman wall painting,
which are particularly interesting in the context of a course on architecture
because as we'll see,
they are so architecturally oriented.
I want to begin with a wall from the house of Salad and we'll go back to palm
pay.
We'll be looking at examples both in Pompeii and Herculaneum and also Rome.
Uh,
I want to look at the house of sal list and palm pay.
And you can see from your monument list that the to bleed them was decorated
with what we call first style Roman wall painting.
That's obviously a modern scholarly,
a designation.
They didn't call it that in ancient Rome or pump pay or Herculaneum,
uh,
first,
first style Roman wall painting this to bleed them in.
This house was decorated in around 100 BC,
which is when we date most of the examples of first style Roman wall painting.
It is very well preserved and it gives us a very good sense of what the Romans
are,
what the,
in this case,
the Pompeians were trying to achieve this style.
The first style of Roman wall painting is also,
you'll see it referred to and your books and your textbooks and scholarship in
general as,
as,
as either the masonry style or the incrustation style.
Uh,
and the reason for this,
both of those are good descriptions because,
uh,
you can see that what is at work here is that the designers are trying to create
a wall.
They're trying to create the illusion that what we're looking at is not a stucco
and paint wall,
which is actually what it's made out of,
but a real marble wall.
We can see that the wall is divided into a series of zones,
architectural zones,
which are exactly the zones that were used in Roman building technique.
We don't quite see it here.
I'll show it to you in another example that there's usually way at the bottom,
a very narrow band,
which is called a plinth.
The plinth is has above it.
Uh,
what's called the Sokal,
a higher,
slightly higher element then what are called the Ortho stats.
The ortho stats are these blocks here.
And then the ice,
uh,
Domenic I.
S.
O.
D.
M.
I see the ISO Domecq courses.
You see those here and then usually either a string course or more likely or in
addition to a cornice,
what's called a corn as a projecting cornice,
e at the top,
so plinth,
Sokal,
orthostatics ice,
adamic blocks,
and then the string course and the cornice,
which again corresponds to actual Roman building technique,
but more important than those,
that terminology is again,
what's they are trying to achieve here.
It is clear when you look at,
well first of all,
keep in mind that this is not flat.
It's a relief.
It's a relief wall and the wall has been built up in relief through stucco.
They've taken the rubble wall,
they've added Stucco and they made that stucco look like a series of blocks that
are divided by the string courses.
Then what they've done is painted those blocks and they painted those blocks.
Not all one color,
not all Pompei and red,
but all different kinds of colors,
green and red and pink and Beige and sometimes multicolored is,
we'll see what is the implication here?
What the implication here is that we are looking,
that they're trying to create the illusion through a stucco and paint of a
marble wall of a marble wall.
That would have been very expensive to build because you would have had to bring
all of these multicolored marbles,
which you could not find in Italy from places very far away from North Africa or
from the Asia minor or from Greece.
You'd have to bring or from Egypt,
you'd have to bring it from very,
very,
very far away.
And that would cost a tremendous amount of money.
So what they are saying here is I am,
I,
I'm the owner of this house.
I am wealthy enough to be able to afford a bringing marble from all over the
world and using it to decorate my,
uh,
my,
to bleeding them.
Now,
was anyone fooled that this was a real marble wall and not a painted wall?
We'll probably not.
Uh,
but the idea was to give one the sense that this was a very expensive wall.
and we'll see one of the most,
well I'll,
I'll hold that till later cause I thought to later,
here's another example in the same house.
This is the house of Salus.
We are looking,
we have just here's the to bleed them wall that we just looked at.
We are uh,
we are now in the Atrium of the house or what survives of the Atrium of the
house.
We were looking at two of the cubicles that opened off the atrium.
And if you look at the walls you can see again the same effect that the rubble
wall has been covered with Stucco,
that the stucco has been divided,
stucco has been built up in relief,
that it has been divided into a series of architectural zones.
And then the individual blocks and the Ortho stat level and in the ice Dominic
level have been painted different colors.
Again,
to give this illusion that what we are looking at is a marble wall,
not a painted wall.
So an attempt attempt to make something to fictionalize and make something seem
more than it actually is.
Here's another view,
a restored view that gives you a sense perhaps of what this might have looked
like when the colors were more vivid.
We do believe that those Qubica had doors,
probably wooden doors that no longer survive.
Uh,
and you can see not only the architectural courses here,
but the effect that this would have had.
He is one of these multicolored blocks.
Again,
a marble that would have had to be brought,
uh,
from,
north Africa or somewhere like that where they had these kinds of multicolored
marbles.
But this gives you some sense of what the appearance would have been perhaps
from a distance.
You,
you're,
I really would have been fooled into thinking that this was a real marble wall.
You'll remember the restored view I showed you of the House of the fon where we
stood again in the atrium.
Uh,
looking back at the statute of the phone and I mentioned that the walls were
decorated with first style Roman wall painting.
And so we see that again here and we see the kind of effect it would have had if
the entire space was covered with this kind of wall paint.
And you can also see the relationship between those paintings and the vista that
one saw as when stood and looked back,
uh,
through the columns onto the additional columns of the Paris style court.
Another example of a first style wall,
this one from Herculaneum is the so called Sam Night House,
which we saw earlier today with that fabulous atrium,
the Sam [inaudible] house.
And this is the foul case of the Sam Night House.
Also dates to 100 BC.
And you can see the same scheme as we already saw.
One additional feature that you can see better here is the plinth.
This very narrow band that we see at the bottom of the plinth,
the Sokal here,
the Ortho stats here,
uh,
the ice adamic courses here,
the string course,
and then the corners.
So exactly the same scheme that we saw in the other house at Pompei.
We see here in the [inaudible] house at Herculaneum.
This one even better preserved.
And that's actually a very washdot view,
but I can show you a better one a where you can get a better sense of the
coloration of this particular wall,
the plinth,
the softball,
the Ortho stats,
the isoc don't mix and then a phrase as you can see in between the string course
and the corners,
there is a red freeze a,
and look at this.
This is better preserved so that you can get a better sense again of what this
might have looked like in ancient Roman times.
This wonderful contrast between the reddish porphyry Lightstone that probably
would have come from Egypt,
the multi grained a stone that might've come from North Africa.
The kind of impact that this would have had,
but again,
most important for us is what they're trying to do is create an illusion there,
crying,
trying to create,
just make something look like something.
It really isn't.
They are using again a stucco and paint to make a wall to make a very plain wall
to make a rubble and stucco and painted wall into a very grandiose wall that
looked like walls that were probably the kinds of walls.
In fact,
we shore.
They were the kinds of walls that decorated the palaces of great Hellenistic
kings and the Hellenistic east.
We know that the great kings of Pergamon and some of the other uh,
kingdoms had palaces that had real marble walls and we think it's very likely
that that is the sort of thing that they are trying to recreate here.
And then a very,
a,
a particularly important point I think is the fact that even though I would love
to lay claim to this particular style for the Romans,
the Romans did not invent the first style of Roman wall painting.
They copied it from the Greeks.
We know that the Greeks used this first style of Roman wall paint,
whatever,
whenever it wasn't called the Dot Roman wall painting obviously for them.
But they used something comparable to the first style,
which we believe was derived from these Hellenistic palaces.
Ultimately,
uh,
and you can see here a view of a wall or a drawing of a wall that was in,
and it's on your monument list from the House of the Trident on the island of de
Los,
late second,
early first century BC.
Uh,
the island of de Los was a strategically located between,
with located,
between,
um,
uh,
it'll Italy and Greece and Asia minor and so on.
It was one of these crossroads of trade.
Uh,
and it was a place where Romans settled in the late,
uh,
first as a for centuries BC especially.
And we see houses there.
Uh,
probably some Greek owners,
some Roman owners that have this same kind of style.
It's painted.
We see the same zones.
I won't describe them again at the same architectural zones that we see in the
first style paintings in,
uh,
in Pompeii and Herculaneum.
Uh,
but,
uh,
and,
and we believe that those are based on Hellenistic precedents,
but they show us again that this was used in the Greek east,
was probably picked up by some of the traders,
brought back to Italy and use their,
the fact that it's a Greek import is extremely important because it then we can
group it with all the other Greek imports that we've been talking about,
the columns,
the Paris styles,
the Alexander mosaic,
all of the things that,
that the,
um,
that the Romans,
the Helen Ising,
uh,
elements that we have seen the Romans be particularly fond of in this early
period and have used themselves in their architecture and in their architectural
decor.
So we see that here again,
the taking over of a Greek style of organizing and decorating a wall,
uh,
for these Roman buildings.
This is a house we'll look at later in the semester at Ostia,
the road port city of Ostia,
this so called house of cupid and psyche.
And we see the two lovers here on a pedestal in the center.
I show it to here only.
It's a much later structure,
but I show it to only because we will see when we get to that that the Romans do
and we'll see it much earlier than that.
In fact,
the Romans do begin to Revet,
uh,
some of their structures with marble.
This begins already in the age of Augustus,
so we'll see it very soon.
Uh,
and eventually it becomes part of house design as well.
So while this isn't a,
as,
as grandiose as a Hellenistic palace would have been,
it does give you some idea of what a house would look like or a palace would
look like that had marble on the floor and marble on the walls.
And it's this kind of thing,
uh,
that they are trying to create the illusion of this is very subtle with pastels
and so on,
but it's this kind of thing that they are trying to create the illusion of with
the Roman for style.
We see first style Roman wall painting also in,
I'm also in Rome.
And in fact,
I can show you an even more spectacular example in Rome.
It's from the house of the griffins.
And I show you a view into a great barrel vaulted room.
We're walking along the Carter have a great barrel vaulted room in the house of
the griffins in Rome on the Palatine Hill.
In fact under the later Imperial Palace of the emperor Domitian,
it dates to 80 BC.
This particular room which we call room three dates to the eight to ADBC.
It's from this room that the house gets its name because you can get a glimpse
of,
and I'll show you a better view in a moment of the griffins.
There are heraldic Griffin's in a lunette painted red in the background they're
made out of.
They're built up and stucco and then the lunette itself is painted red.
It's from those Griffin's if the house got its name,
we are looking down the side of that house and we see again that that is built
up in Stucco so it's still a kind of stucco relief.
But if you look at the paintings on the walls and on the back wall,
the sidewall and the back wall and I'll show you a better view here.
You will see that although we are dealing with something that looks like a first
style wall,
it's very flat.
It's decided divided into architectural zones.
Uh,
the softball,
the Ortho stats,
the ice adamic courses here,
that is all done entirely in paint.
As you can see,
it's not built up as a relief.
The only relief here that we see is the relief that is used for the heraldic
Griffin's up in the upper most part.
When this was in better condition,
it was a painting was made of it.
And I showed that painting to you here and I hope this will give you a better
sense than anything else I've shown you today of how glorious these things must
have been in antiquity and how again,
if you stood back from them,
you might have been somewhat fooled.
Uh,
we see the wall here.
We can see all the components that we've already described,
the plinth,
the softball,
the Ortho stats,
the ice Domenic courses,
and then the lunette with the heraldic griffins.
Uh,
and again,
the whole idea of this being to give you the impression that you were looking at
a real marble wall,
even though you are looking at a painted,
much more important for the development of Roman painting is another house that
I'm going to show you.
OOPS,
okay.
Who was going to show you?
Okay.
Here,
uh,
which is room two in the house of the griffins and while,
and the states a little bit later,
it was done between 80 and 60 BC.
And we look at this,
we will see that there are beginning to be some important changes here.
Uh,
as you look at this,
you see where looking at a barrel vaulted room,
once again,
uh,
walls decorate and we'll all three walls well decorated and very well preserved
so we can see exactly what's going on here.
As we look quickly,
we see remnants of the first style wall.
We see that we have the same architectural zones,
the plinths,
the orthos stats,
the Ice Doma,
uh,
ice to doma courses.
And we have the same idea of marble.
You can see that these very gated marble blocks and these red,
uh,
red panels are meant to look again like marble.
Although this is done entirely in paint,
there is no stucco die in used in this room whatsoever.
STUCCO is not used anywhere here.
This is completely flat and it is painted as an illusionistic view.
But as we look at this,
we see,
although we get a sense that that first cell wall is kind of present,
uh,
we also see some,
again,
very important changes.
We see the way in which they've treated the Sokal here to create these kinds of
illusionistic cubes that look almost as if they're projecting out into our
space.
Look also at what they've done by adding columns,
columns that stand on basis,
this colonnade that seems to encircle the room the way a peristyle in circles,
a garden court,
this introduction of columnar architecture,
again,
clearly under the influence of Greek architecture and clearly commensurate with
what they're doing in temple architecture,
what they're doing in,
uh,
in,
um,
in sanctuary architecture and also in house architecture.
So we see those columns and it looks as if those columns are resting on bases
that are represented in as if they're receding into the background.
They artists has paid a lot of attention to trying to render them perspectively.
So although all of this is done in paint,
we get the impression that what we're looking at is a colonnade that is in front
of the wall.
It projects into the spectators space and that what lies behind it is a kind of
first style wall.
This is the very beginnings of what we call second style Roman wall painting.
This introduction of columns,
this introduction of elements that project into the viewer space,
the sense that you are looking at two levels of space,
the level of space that is the wall and then the level of space that projects in
front of it and look at the columns at the top of the columns.
You will see they whole lintels.
But those lintels also are shown is if they're receding into depth and you can
sort of barely see and you'll see this better as you study this on the,
in the online images,
you'll be able to see the actual a coffered ceiling,
uh,
that is represented on the top or underneath those lintels,
which again indicate that this is being,
uh,
this is um,
being represented in depth.
And here you can see exactly what they're trying to do.
They're trying to use paint and only paint to recreate the sort of thing that we
saw in built architecture in the [inaudible],
in the house of the a silver wedding.
These columns that project in front of a painted wall,
this is the PSD raises dawns of,
of what we call second style Roman wall painting.
This is the preeminent example of mature a second style Roman wall painting.
It is a,
a scene in the villa of the mysteries.
It's in one of the cubicles cubicles,
cubic Ulum 16 at the bill of the mysteries and Pompei it dates to 60 to 50 BC.
It's a further development of what we saw in room two of the house of the
griffins.
We see the first style wall is still present.
We see the plinth,
we see the sock,
we see the orthostatics,
we see the ice adamic blocks,
although they are done entirely in paint.
Again,
no stucco here whatsoever.
We see the columns have also added as is typical of second style.
But here the columns are even more interesting because we can see that the
columns not only project from the wall themselves but they support and in
tablature,
e n t a,
B,
l e t,U r e n n,
tablature,
which projects out toward the spectator.
And they tried to make that look as if it recedes into depth.
We see another set of columns here,
uh,
that support a straight Lindell.
But then look the,
the Lintel arches up in the center.
This is called an RQ weighted lintel and RQ weighted lintel.
We have not seen an RQ weighted lintel in built architecture.
This is very early 60 to 50 BC.
We are seeing it here.
Why are we seeing it here and why are we not seeing it?
In built architecture is a very interesting issue.
In one we could debate in the online forum,
we see that that first style wall has been,
oh,
and we also see columns that support one of these lentils with a coffered
ceiling.
Uh,
the Brown coffered ceiling up at the upper most part,
the first stall wall is a very complex painting and a very interesting painting.
Intellectually.
The first all wall has been,
it's there,
but it's been dropped down.
It's been dropped down.
And now we can see something that lies behind.
Behind that first style wall we see a view of,
of this round a structure called a thorough loss.
T h o l o s around thoughtless.
It's like the throw loss that was at the top of the sanctuary of Fortuna premed
Jania at Palestrina.
It's a shrine of some sort and that shrine is surrounded by blue sky.
So that's something that's presumably outside.
So the first style wall has been dropped down and now we have this vista or
panorama of something that lies outside the wall.
So we inset in a sense have three zones of space.
We have the columns that project into the spectators space.
We have the first style or the what's left of the first style wall,
and then we see a view through the wall to something that lies beyond a vista,
a panorama,
a window.
It's like opening up the wall as a window to what lies beyond this fictive.
Again,
in the same way that first stall wall painting was fictive,
it creates an illusion of something that is there that isn't really there and it
coincides certainly with the kind of development we've been tracing.
Also in built architecture,
this opening up at the house,
opening up of the windows,
opening up bay windows to views that lie beyond.
There's also these mysterious things that are called the people usually refer to
as the black curtains in second style Roman wall painting.
You can see this black element that looks almost as if it were a curtain that's
been dropped down to reveal the scene that lies beyond because of this and
because of the columns,
the projecting columns.
Many scholars have suggested that there's some relationship between this and
theatrical Roman are theatrical architecture.
The attrical architecture that was probably stage sets in the like that were
probably initially made out of wood that don't survive any longer.
Uh,
and that these may imitate,
uh,
some of those stage sets and that this may be an actual curtain using theatrical
performances.
But there are other ways to think about,
uh,
those black curtain so to speak.
And I think we don't have time to do that here now,
but we should definitely engage on that in the online forum.
I want to show you,
oh,
and I do want to say one last thing.
We're going to look at one more example of second cell Roman wall painting.
Uh,
one thing,
one distinction that I want to make between the first and the second style is
while the first style of Roman wall painting was a Greek import,
there is nothing like the second style is,
we've just described it anywhere in Greek art.
Uh,
the second style of Roman wall painting is without any question,
a Roman innovation and an extraordinary Roman innovation at that.
And one that is very closely allied with developments in architecture as we've
described them.
This is another example,
The v the villa,
a Publius Fanis Sinise store,
second style painting dates to 50 to 40 BC.
Uh,
it was in that town of Bus Gloriola that I showed you on the map before between
Herculaneum and Pompei.
Uh,
and it had,
it was removed from there at one point and made its way to New York.
Uh,
it is now in the metropolitan and has been for a long time in the Metropolitan
Museum of art.
It is usually referred to as the met cubic ulum.
And if you haven't seen it,
you should go down and see it.
It is most extraordinary.
They've tried to recreate the,
the paintings are all ancient of,
but they tried to recreate the ambiance by putting a black and white mosaic on
the floor and giving us a nice comfortable sort of bed,
uh,
and a footstool over here,
that are,
you know,
just have the kind of thing that you would have seen in that room,
although they don't actually belong.
Uh,
and they've added a window.
And so on and so forth.
But the paintings are all are genuine ancient paintings.
And what's amazing is we have the entire spread of the room and actually there
are mirror images.
The scenes are mirror images of one another across the two long walls.
I want to show you just a couple of details and this is a detail from that room
that shows a thorough loss,
uh,
seen through columns.
Uh,
once again,
we see here,
this is example of second style,
but it's a little bit more developed here because you can see that the first
style wall,
uh,
has really been dropped down now.
And in fact,
it doesn't even look like a first style wall anymore.
It just looks like a red parapet,
uh,
with a,
with a green freeze and a little corners at the top.
But it doesn't really look like a first I'll wall.
In fact,
it looks like a wall with a gate that doesn't look like there's any knob or
anything like that.
So we kind of wondered,
can we get into this?
We have to jump over it.
How do we get from here into what lies beyond,
we're not absolutely sure,
uh,
but we see a third loss,
once again,
one of these sort of sacred shrines.
And here you can see it is surrounded by a peristyle,
by columns,
a peristyle just like one might find in a house,
in a house or in a villa.
So what are we looking at here?
We have,
we see columns that support a pediment.
The pediment,
if you look a triangular pediment,
what's interesting about it and is it's broken at the bottom,
the Greeks would never break their pediments.
Uh,
the Romans have broken this pediment to allow space for the thorough loss to
rise up between it.
That's a very interesting thing to do.
And it shows,
while on one hand they respect ancient Greek architecture.
They're also willing to depart from it and break the rules,
so to speak.
And we're going to see that's,
uh,
that's,
emphasized by the Romans later on.
So the thought of loss here.
So we have these different elements.
We have the columns projecting toward us.
We have the wall of the,
of the gateway.
We also have this view through the window picture window into what lies beyond
and we seem to have these black curtains again.
In fact we have three of these black curtains.
So we ask ourselves again,
what are those exactly?
And another view of just showing you this in relationship to the house of the
fawn and uh,
this whole idea of Vista and panorama from one part to another.
We see the same thing happening in painting as we see happening in that.
And then one last detail of the,
uh,
of the uh,
Publius [inaudible] over here,
a very interesting detail and I urge you to explore this on your own because
it's so fascinating in detail,
this doorway.
And then most interesting of all this panoply of,
uh,
of structures that are,
that seem to be piled one on top of another in a series of stories.
This again is very early.
It's 60,
it's 50 to 40,
50 to 40 BC.
We don't see anything like that and build architecture.
Then we only see second story's beginning to be added and palm pay instructors
Herculaneum structures between the earthquake and the,
and Vesuvius.
Between 62 and 79,
but here already in the mid century BC,
we see this depicted in paint.
Is this fanciful?
Is it based on something that was built in wood that no longer survives?
These are questions,
perhaps unanswerable questions,
but one one's well worth pondering.
I want to show you in the few minutes that remain,
uh,
just two more houses quickly.
Uh,
one of them,
both of them are important though,
uh,
because they belong to the emperor and empress to Augustus and to Livia.
Augustus purchased some property on the Palatine Hill.
He wanted to live his Rome's first emperor of Rome.
He wanted to live where Romulus had lived before him.
Of course.
Uh,
and uh,
he buys some property up here,
builds a house.
Uh,
he puts a,
uh,
a uh,
temple to his patron,
God right next door,
Apollo.
And then Olivia has her own house right across the street.
His wife living,
she lives with him in his house,
but she's also got her own house right across the street.
Uh,
and both of these houses were decorated with paintings.
I want to show you first the ones in the house of Augustus,
the most famous room in the house of Augustus called the room of the masks.
And here is where we see most clearly the possible relationship between Roman
wall painting of the second style cause.
This is also second style Roman wall painting and the theater,
if you look at the uh,
uh,
of the restored view at the top of a typical theater facade is we think it would
have looked a theater stage building as we think it would have looked early on,
possibly made out of wood.
Again rather than stone.
You can see it as the central section with a pediment and then it has two wings
and we say the same scheme here,
the central section,
which is called technically a red [inaudible] in theater architecture,
r,
e g,
I a and then two wings that are technically called Husky Talia,
l I a Haas be Talia.
So this tripartite scheme of a Roman theater.
And if that is lost on us,
note that there are masks,
one on either side,
theatrical masks that also give us a hint that we are looking at a theater set.
Here's a more vivid view of one of the walls where you can see that tripartite
division and to central section and two wings.
You can see the masks and you can see a view into some sort of landscape.
The Sky is no longer blue,
it's white,
but it does continue back beyond behind the architecture.
So you get the sense that you're being beckoned into.
There's no,
in fact,
there's no barrier here at all.
The Wall is gone here.
There's no gateway.
You can walk right in to this.
What is this is there's no blue skies,
so it doesn't look as real as the others did.
It's not the sort of thing that might have been right outside your window of a
house.
It's some kind of sacred landscapes and kind of strange sacred landscape with a
curved colonnade,
with a tree,
and with a very phallic looking,
um,
uh,
shrine here in the center,
some kind of sacred space.
We call these sacro idyllic landscape,
sort of idyllic and sacred at the same time that you're being beckoned into to
explore again,
is this a stage set of some sort or is it something else?
Is it something that makes religious Kalanick to religious connotations?
The other interesting thing about the room of the masks and the house of
Augustus is that some scholars have claimed that although it is usually said
that one point linear perspective in which all lines converge at a single point
in the distance was created in the rent.
It was invented in the renaissance.
A case can be made that it was invented in Roman times.
Uh,
and if,
if it happened,
it happened here in this house ware and scholars even of the renaissance have
studied the way in which these points converge in this painting all the way to a
point at the end.
So if that's true,
uh,
the Romans may have done that perhaps inadvertently,
perhaps on purpose.
They were very interested in perspective.
I'll say a bit more about that in a moment.
Uh,
but if they invented it here,
they quickly rejected it.
As we're going to see in next week's lecture,
just a couple of details.
The mask and the beautiful way in which this very talented artists,
probably one of the best artists of the day,
as built up this mask out of,
uh,
out of,
you know,
touches of gray and white and black.
Uh,
an extraordinary thing.
And then again,
I really do urge you to,
uh,
to look at these,
look at these paintings in detail because if you do,
you will be very rewarded.
You'll see all kinds of strange creatures like wing had figures,
uh,
this very strange thing lurking up there.
Is that vegetal is it animal as a human?
I mean,
what is that?
Uh,
these wonderful what looked like swans,
golden swans decorate this,
that when you look very close,
you can see this a figural freeze here and look at that wonderful representation
of the fruit or vegetables in a bowl,
a bowl that has represented so magnificently and translucent,
Lee,
uh,
by the artist and the in the maybe three minutes or so that remain,
I want to show you one last painting and it's a very special painting indeed and
I think it ties together everything that we've been talking about today.
It is a painting from not the house of Livia where there are some freezer
paintings.
We're not going to look at those,
but from a villa of Livia located north of Rome at a place called Prima Porta,
the villa of Livia at Prima Porta.
And it is the,
in a sense,
the ultimate example and the very last gasp of second style Roman wall painting,
the villa was put up in 30 to 25 BC.
A barrel vaulted room was decorated with this garden escape.
Now,
as you look at this,
you'd probably say to me that's has doesn't look like anything we've looked at
today.
There's no architecture there.
There's no remnants of a first stall wall there,
no project in columns.
There are no black curtains and so on and so forth.
It's very different from anything we've seen,
but we categorize this as a second style wall.
Why do we do that?
Because there's a division between where we stand a spectator and the space that
lies beyond the fence.
There is a fence divides our space when the space that lies outside,
but it's a very uh,
various very delicate fence and wear a white kind of lattice spends not unlike
the one we saw in the Sam night house.
On the second story,
we don't have columns.
We have trees at different kind of upright here.
But what connects this to the second style is that it is the ultimate example of
a Roman painting as a panoramic picture window.
This is what this was the,
this is what they hoped.
You would see when you looked out of the rooms of your house,
of your great bay window.
In the bill of the mysteries.
You didn't see the see,
you would see some glorious landscape out a garden scape out aside of your
window with beautiful trees.
This is,
if you look at these with care,
you will see that this is an artist who understood nature and observed at,
who knew the difference between among the fruits that would be on trees like
this,
their fruit trees here,
who knew,
who had a sense of the way in which birds would a light on a leaf if they were
headed toward one who had a sense of the way in which leaves would Russell in
the breeze who had a sense of the way in which light can fall differently on a
leaf so that you sometimes see the lighted side or the side and shadow.
This is an artist who has really observe nature and has depicted what he saw.
And here are a couple of details where you can see that very well of this tree.
You see what I mean by some leaves Caston Shadow.
Some leaves have light shining on them.
Uh,
you get a sense of the breeze.
You get this wonderful,
the wonderful way in which this black bird,
a lights on the edge of a leaf.
This bird over here,
uh,
surveying this piece of fruit,
deciding whether he wants to peck it or not.
This is very sophisticated stuff.
Uh,
and you can also see if you explore this,
this painting a bit more that it has in it,
it partakes of what we call today atmospheric perspective.
Not One point perspective but atmospheric perspective.
What does atmospheric perspective,
if you look at this carefully,
you will see that all of the items that are in all the objects that are in the
foreground have very distinct outlines.
Whereas those in the middle ground or a little fuzzier and those way in the
background are fuzzy,
are still,
and they're actually probably could barely see them,
but they're actually mountains in the distance and those mountains in the
distance are so fuzzy in their silhouette that you can barely see them,
but you get the sense of space of moving back because of this use of atmospheric
perspective.
So this the ultimate Roman painting second style,
the Roman painting as Panorama,
that again corresponds so well,
uh,
to all the discussions we've been having the last couple of lectures of this
move towards increased vista,
increased Panorama,
both in painting and also in architecture.
Thanks guys.